Now that we've dispelled the idea that you should just make a big unit table,
and we've gotten familiar with fact tables and dimension tables,
it's time to learn how to load and transform our data with Power Query.
Recall from our Power BI pipeline that this
is our starting layer that we'll use to create
a data model before generating that user-friendly visual report layer.
In this lesson, we'll focus on Power Query.
Let's zoom in a bit on this part of the process.
First, of course, we need to access the data,
and we'll learn how to do this using the Get Data feature.
Let's take a look together at the options you have at
your fingertips to pull together data from Power BI and discuss
some creative approaches you can take if Power BI doesn't
already have a ready connection for what you need out of the box.
Power BI supports a huge range of data sources.
We'll learn about some of these in this lesson as well as where to
go to see what additional data sources are available.
Next, we'll learn how to tidy up the data to make it easy for you,
your end users, and Power BI itself to easily find and use the data you need.
The initial data we get from a query
before we've tidied it up can have a whole bunch of issues.
We'll use some basic transformations to make sure
our data is nicely cleaned up and without any clutter.
This will involve things like making sure our data is clearly labeled,
that we have all the right columns,
and that these columns have logical headers,
and that we've also removed any null rows that are just taking up space.
This queues up our data for either data model usage or
the more significant transformations we'll go through in an upcoming lesson.
Another important part of preparing our data will involve identifying and using
the correct data types so that calculations and visualizations will work as intended.
This might sound obvious,
but using the wrong data types when you're first
getting the data can cause trouble later on when you go to generate your report.
To give a really simple example,
you might have some sales data like we have here.
Suppose you want to add up the subtotals to get the sum of all the sales,
but you find that you're unable to sum them and that
your only option for aggregating this value is instead by count.
The reason is that when you ran your original query,
you used the wrong data type for this subtotal column.
What looks like a numerical value here or
numerical values here are actually stored as text strings.
In this lesson, we'll learn how to use the correct data types so we
avoid issues like this where having the wrong data type will get in our way.
Finally, we'll get into the syntax of the M formula language to help you better
understand how to make corrections after
the fact once you've made some preliminary transformations.
By the end of this lesson,
we'll know how to load and tidy up our data so that it's ready
for the more advanced transformation wizardry we'll be doing later,
and it will have the right structure and data types we need for the final report.
By the end of this lesson,
we'll know how to load and tidy up our data so
that it is ready for the more advanced transformation
wizardry we'll be doing later and has
the right structure and data types we need for the final report.